this is now being pushed on children
there was
this is the most disturbing commercial
i've ever seen i have a little series on
my youtube channel
of woke commercials where we try to
guess what product the woke commercials
are selling
this one i wouldn't i wouldn't do as a
separate woke commercial
breakout video it's too disturbing for
that but we do have to cover it because
the issue really matters this is a
commercial from pantene
the shampoo company now
defending mainstreaming the
sexual abuse of children in a commercial
in which two lesbian women dress a boy
up a little boy up
as a little girl and insist that the boy
really is a girl
take a listen
[Music]
so you've got this woman blow drying the
little boy's now long hair
it's how you are seen sawyer is an old
soul
she is our uh spunky and
creative kiddo sawyer also happens to be
a transgender girl so says this woman
the first time
she was out in the community wearing the
clothing she wanted in her hair and
she kind of was herself and that was the
first day where i saw her pause it right
there
pause it right there so first of all i
don't know how these
lesbian women came to have custody of
this girl
something tells me they didn't make her
the old-fashioned way i'm sorry see how
confusing this is
i don't know how these lesbian women
came to have custody of this boy that
they are now dressing up as a girl and
insisting is a girl
and i am certain that they they did not
make him the old-fashioned way
this raises other political and social
questions
but what this woman just said is so
awful
this woman said yeah i took my little
boy out and dressed him up as a girl
and and and that's when she
was herself when we pretended that the
little boy was a little girl
that's finally when she was herself and
then here's the kicker
and that was the first day where i saw
her
where i so this woman is saying that
this
child however she came to be raising
this child
this woman didn't didn't see the child
when the little boy was still dressing
like a little boy
only when the little boy allowed this
woman to dress him up as a little girl
only then
did this woman see the child and accept
the child
keep going she has always been
super gender creative pause gender
creative
she has always been super gender
creative so obviously that's a term that
doesn't mean anything just
i suppose it could mean confused but
what do we mean always
from from the time that the little boy
was a very little baby
when the little boy didn't have agency
when the little boy
was so suggestible to all the all the
influences around him
was that him being gender creative or
was that
these women with a very radical view of
sexuality
imposing that view on this
young boy keep going it's been a big
part of her transition
once she told us that she identified as
a girl
she immediately wanted to grow her hair
out it made me feel good and confident
and it made my insides match my outsides
all right i can't take anymore pause it
there if you want to watch the rest of
the commercial you can though i wouldn't
recommend it
so they've got this this little boy and
they've put this little boy on camera
and said okay that's what you're going
to say we've got the whole
studio set up here talk about how now
your insides are matching your outsides
right this is this is not an organic
moment
you don't set up a film shoot
organically that's not how these things
are edited or cut this is a obvious
not just contrived in the sense that
parents and educators
are contriving you know indoctrinating
views
onto children but but even the whole
film set here
and what is so crazy politically the
reason
i mention this is because it's all to
sell shampoo
it's all to sell shampoo
if this is what capitalism is i'm out
i'm out get me out of there okay but of
course this is not frankly the word
capitalism is kind of silly so it's a
word that was popularized by karl marx
but i think this should show
conservatives who are waking up to these
questions now
that there are immoral things that can
happen
in the the free marketplace that free
markets are wonderful i love free
markets
free markets are a means to an end which
is a good
society right that's what societies are
always pursuing the good human
flourishing
and those markets can be perverted and
lead society down perverse ends
these women what they are doing and how
they are abusing this child should be
criminal
this should not be legal they should be
imprisoned for this in a just
society and and pantene pro-v or
whatever the
you know whatever the product is should
not only be ashamed of itself should not
only be boycotted this sort of thing
should not be permitted i think a lot of
conservatives are waking up now
to say oh right we we love markets
in their proper place but we need guard
rails on society or
the society that we talk about we love
free markets we love big businesses
it's going to eat itself it's going to
undermine itself
capitalism corporate america is going to
become the biggest vessel
for radical woke-ism radical leftism
that is going to totally subvert
the culture unless we conserve something
beyond
low tax rates really
really spooky stuff
speaking of weird sex stuff i have to
get to the most important story
of our of our day teen vogue
i have assiduously avoided reading about
the teen vogue saga
editors being fired and claims of racism
and
disism and that ism but
it actually shows us something about the
cancel culture
and these these kind of drastically
political visions that the left and
right are putting forward
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]